foreign
Stockton California home of the Diaz
brothers and talk to Alex what's up Alex
hi John how are you doing good how are
you
um hopefully better after this call oh
there's been two tough ones so give me
an easy one
oh in that case that I can't all right
I'm here with you let's do it what's up
okay so let me start by the question
um
is there
into help or stop my 12 year old
daughter from getting bullied
um
ghoul
yeah
yeah all right so
as you can imagine I've dealt with this
situation for my whole career so I'm
gonna go all the way to the back and I'm
gonna ask you a few questions they're
going to sound hard is that okay
yeah okay
well actually before I do that explain
to me teach me about the bowling what's
going on
past um I believe three years
she had
they I've constantly been called I've
went there I've huffed and puffed and
demanded to talk to the bully's parents
and it is impossible
I can't even set up a meeting with the
parents I can't even leave my phone
number to the parents it's like they cut
off complete communication or any kind
of like negotiation
I I feel like the school is just
I'm mad I'm sad I'm just like a mix of
emotions
well
I uh I'm gonna do something I really
don't do but I understand the school's
position on this one usually I'm
complaining about the schools
I would I'm glad that kids can't come to
school and demand con my contact
information and call me
I think that's I think that's unwise you
see you know what I'm saying I get that
but I also that you want you want
Justice
and tell me what's what they're doing to
your daughter
uh they're constantly calling our names
and um every time that I go and complain
to the office it's like she they start
calling her a snitch and um so she stops
telling me
but I can tell she's still going through
it
and what's the school's response
so this first let's do this first and
then it's been three years Sean like
where is gonna be the final the the
finale where are we gonna get to the
actual response to it
I mean they put her in so many programs
like it just feels like they're more
into trying to make the changes on her
than the actual bullies that might not
be what's happening close doors but
that's how I feel
that's actually been the move okay and
there was
um so bullying is complex right so just
for everybody listening
um bullying is repeated harm it can be
harassment too but it's repeated and it
often
um has a almost I think by definition
has a power hierarchy to it okay so
um
laughs it's the kid who's not the
athletic one and the other Athletics
kids are on to them or they're the not
so pretty because they're going through
an awkward phase and the kids are mean
or they've got braces so there's a
there's a hierarchy there's a power
Dynamic there
um
and for years there was a bunch of
conversations about how to deal with the
bully and a friend of mine named Steve
is a counseling Guru said he was
concerned about this 20 years ago
caused we had stopped teaching kids how
to deal with bullies
and we had just focused fully on a fully
on on the bad guys whoever the bad guys
happen to be and we have to remember bad
guys are kids right so I do expect the
school to come in and say you will not
say those things
and I also expect parents in somewhat
schools to begin to react to or teach
the person who's on the receiving end
especially in what I would call
non-physical violence right you're not
going to die or get put in hospital if
you don't deal with this stuff
um they've got to deal with
they've got to learn those skills
because this is going to be people are
mean right you deal with this out in the
real world right I'll tell you so
um
here's a hard question
what are the things they are saying and
I ask this because there's different
levels of sensitivity and I know I'm
gonna get in trouble on the internet and
that's fine what I'm wondering is this
is the school looking at this situation
and seeing a group of friends
um saying
nice I'm just gonna say what my friend
said
nice face deloni
they used to call me zitcom because I
had bad acne as a kid sitcom they said
all the time
but these are like my best friends in
the world
and it was mean it hurt my feelings but
also I said my things back and we like
that it was just so I wouldn't have been
classified as bullying right
yeah
um and so sometimes there are since
there's kids whose sensitivity alarms is
is more finely tuned and there are
sometimes parents who if their kid comes
home they said something mean just blow
the roof off of everything I'm calling
everybody so
like just as an objective third-party
Outsider I've got a 13 year old myself
what are they saying to your daughter
are they not including her
you know they just saying hey we don't
want you to come to our sleepover party
and that's the bullying you're talking
about like what are we talking about
here
they actually call her names
um I'm not gonna say which names but
they're really insulting about her looks
like you just mentioned
um
and um I've I've explained it to her the
difference between bullying and being a
jerk okay you know and and I I do tell
her like you have to understand there's
some people that have a personality that
you know they're just not happy all the
time and then you have the other people
that are just like picking at you like
poking the bear you know and that's what
she's telling me is happening
um
so there's a bully researcher by the
name of Izzy I think it's comlin Camlin
Coleman Izzy Coleman that's what Izzy
Coleman
and
he talks about one of the corners like
one of the keys of poking the bear is
a bear that is unable to be poked
so I know you've had that conversation
with her when one of these kids says
something about her appearance
and by the way these aren't her friends
like I wouldn't even refer to them as
your friends at school
they clearly are not
if she's been if she's been like hey
that's not funny I don't like that
and they're like nah we do we're gonna
keep doing it
um exactly
then they're not her friends right
um
what is what's the response when you
walk her through like hey you know what
if somebody says something walk away
like they're looking for the response
we're not going to give them their
response because clearly if they're
saying something that ugly there's
something going on in their heart and
mind in their house
so she said that at first she did walk
away like she did walk away but it just
seemed like it wasn't it didn't stop and
I have actually went through bullying
myself and the same thing happened to me
you know I don't feel like walking away
actually helps it it just makes it more
easier for them because they don't get
in trouble for it because all you're
doing is walking away
except that when you accept that when
you tell
it they they double up right not only do
you have braces or not only are you flat
chested or not only do not have the red
hair now you're a snitch too
yeah exactly
so Izzy uh Dr Kellman has a technique
where he will as somebody says
um oh my gosh you're so fat right and
and the response is
you're the most beautiful kid in school
or oh my gosh you're such a slow Runner
well you're the fastest runner out here
and that there's a counterweight that is
so significant to that
and the response is often a one-word
respect like yeah
or huh
now that might be an after school
special response but when I read it it
sounded at least like huh
it's just like I'm not it's so I'm not
playing that game now does that take the
sting out of what they said no
I just I as an educator I found it
harder and harder to legislate that
like because kids are going to say
things to kids they're gonna post things
about kids they're going to write things
in little notes and I get that we want
to stop that if we see it we're gonna
call it out we're gonna bring kids in
and say hey
it's devastating to talk about
somebody's physical appearance don't do
that don't do that
and if I hear about it again you're
going to be in detention
but that's hard right
so I was going to say if even if she did
do that it's going to be a little bit
difficult for her because she's going
through a lot of depression anxiety and
for her to be like positive response
back when she just feels completely down
um that's difficult for her because I've
tried to tell her something like that
and well I totally get it I totally get
it but here's what I want to say you'll
have to choose your heart here
continuing for three years on a track
that's not working
absent take your kid out of school and
that sounds like you just get a kid out
of there well if you're a working parent
in a like in a community that's that's
not always that easy right
um and just I can't just quit working
homeschool you because we got bills to
pay so I there's there's a there's
there's a trapped element here right
um
she's gonna have to choose her hard what
I think y'all should spend some time
doing instead of just telling her you
need to you need to
you'll have to role play this thing
you're gonna have to practice and
practice and practice and practice
almost to the point that it becomes
silly here's how that looks in my house
okay and this is something that I've
been practicing for years is this the
right way to do this I don't think so
but it's a way and it worked for me as a
kid
if I say
gosh it stinks in here
my son will just automatically without
even looking up go you stink
and without even blinking my daughter
will just respond your face stinks
here's what I'm trying to teach them and
I've been teaching this for years in my
house number one
um there's a time and a place
and if there's other adults if I'm being
serious that behavior doesn't happen
but I don't want words from other kids
to have quite the sting
and so we've turned that into a game
yeah their bodies are not going to
respond as though it's a threat now if
they're in love with somebody if this is
their Core group of people different
ball game
but if the instant response is oh I've
played basketball I've got another shot
then then it changes the dynamic okay
that's not for every family and that's
definitely not for every kid so I can't
recommend that but a practice of
um
your shoes are ridiculous those are the
cheap issues well you have the nice
issues it's less about being super
positive and what we're doing is we're
just teaching a different karate kick
right but it's one that's not going to
get anybody in trouble it's just gonna
stop the behavior because here's what we
know
walking away as you said isn't super
helpful
telling on them isn't super helpful
right what are the things you've tried
trying to get in touch with their
parents not super helpful
right so uh uh
can I tell you this one time though that
it actually I felt like a win yeah go
for it um so there was this one time
after I picked up my daughter after
school
and we were driving back home and we see
one of the bullies going into their
house
so I saw where the bully lived and um
and I told my daughter I said tell that
bully that if he doesn't stop we know
where he lives and I'm gonna go talk to
his mom
and the bully my goodness his response
was like I don't give a f
so I was like oh okay he doesn't care no
problem so I go and knock on the door
talk to the mom and the mom acts like
she is so surprised it's the first time
her hearing it even though the school
said that they called her a million
times right
so then I it still happened after that
went back a second time
and I end up telling her listen this has
been going on and this was back a few
months ago so it was like two years I
was like this has been going on for two
years I'm tired of it I'm at my wit's
end
and I'm telling you I I'm gonna put a
juvenile restraining order on your child
on behalf of my daughter which means
that you would have to transfer to a
different school and probably move
because we live really close by
and I don't want to do that that's the
last thing that I want to do
and you're not going to believe it John
that bully stopped completely oh I don't
doubt it for a second yeah I'm done for
a second
um
why haven't you done that to all those
kids why don't you put a restraining
order on them
yeah I and you know what and I've tried
to call the police too by the way
they've been called like twice the first
time it was because my daughter wanted
to um
and her life and she said in his school
and they called the police and they
suggested me to take her to the crisis
center
and um the second time was me calling
them about this building thing and it
just seems like the police is more on
how the school is handling it yeah
yeah well no is there an option is there
an option to take her out of this
situation just get her out of the mess
yeah but you know I feel like
transferring is not going to do anything
the bullies are still going to bully if
it's not my daughter's going to be
someone else I understand that but right
now let's take care of your daughter
like you're right there's a longer game
to play here but every day this thing
goes on your daughter's is is at the in
the middle of it
yeah and at least it gives a control alt
delete for your daughter because she's
gonna have to learn some skills
yeah we cannot have a culture where
everybody is walking around because it
just because that window gets narrower
narrower and narrower and narrower right
yeah and so she's gonna have to what I
mean by that the window gets narrower
from what hurts my feelings and what I
consider bullying versus what you
consider bullying and it and then all of
a sudden none of us can move
yeah and then the only move is start
canceling people right that's been our
culture the last five or six years
gonna have to learn some skills on
standing up for herself on not accepting
this on walking away on appropriately
challenging back
um Etc
and that will help with as she learns
gains confidence in those responses that
will help her entire psyche
and you're watching your daughter
shrivel up in front of you over the last
three years get her out of this
environment man if you can get her out
you're right and then we'll play the
long game fair
I don't want you to look at this like
you lost I want you to look at this like
you saved your daughter's life
okay
you're right
because I feel like you're going to war
with a bunch of 13 year olds and 12 year
olds
and I feel like you're gone to war with
12 year olds and parents that you've
never met and may never meet
and you're going to war against a school
that isn't doing enough to protect your
daughter and you're going to war against
a young girl's mental health challenges
that are continued dwindle in front of
you what I'm gonna tell you is quit
going to war
foreign
get your daughter out of this mess take
her to a safe place
and then you can begin teaching her some
skills then y'all can practice at home
not in the car on the way to work like
all right so if anyone says anything
you're just gonna say no no we're just
gonna role play at home
now yo shoes are stupid oh you've got
great shoes
you can't even run right is that fun
when you say that
yeah hmm
we're just gonna practice those things
and it may not pay off when she's 13. it
may not pay off she's 14 but when she's
19 in college and somebody says
something like that man she's gonna have
a skill set that many 19 year olds don't
have
and so everybody listening to this
um
this bullying stuff is such a disaster
it's such a mess because it's so clear
that it destroys kids and it's also so
clear that it's kids doing it's kids
trying to be funny or kids trying to not
feel less than and it's hard to
legislate that it's very hard
because you can Outlaw saying mean
things but that's going to be subjective
across the board and you can Outlaw
um if you say this one more time to this
kid you are out of here which I think
should have happened in this case and
the school has chosen not to do that for
whatever reason
I'm going to double down if I can if any
possibility and get my kid out of there
I'm also going to double down and try to
teach my kid some skills and if I don't
have those skills we're going to give
with a child counselor we're going to
figure these skills out work with the
school counselor at this new school
banging my head for three years because
the whole time I'm banging my head my
kid is going to school there every day
every day there every day
and parents if you have a kid who's a
jerk
stop it
stop it it's not funny it's funny when
my seven-year-old makes a joke at my
expense that's funny but we're all in it
together
but you'll never hear my daughter do
that to somebody else because she's too
sensitive
she cares too much about other people
raise kids who care about other people
um
bullying starts and stops in the house
often
stop
because there's another little kid on
the other side of this that's trapped